Bitte schön.
Ja, hallo, guten Tag.
Guten Tag.
Ibrahim Usta ist mein Name
und ich bin heute zuständig Arzt für Sie
und ich möchte mit Ihnen über Ihre Beschwerden sprechen.
Aber zuerst brauche ich eine Einfache für Sennian-Daten
und danach sprechen wir genau über Ihre Beschwerden.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja.
Wie lautet Ihr Name?
Ich heiße Mario Dietrich.
Mario Dietrich.
Können Sie bitte den Nachnamen Buch stabilieren?
Ja, D-I-E-T-R-I-C-H.
C-H, ja Dietrich.
Und mein Vorname ist Mario, ich bin ein Mann.
Ja, Herr Dietrich.
Genau.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 17.09.83.
17.09.83.
Okay.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Noch bin ich 39.
Ich werde im September 40.
Ja, 39. Okay.
Wie viel wiegen Sie zurzeit?
79 kg, glaube ich.
69.
79.
Okay, 79.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
1,84 m.
84.
Okay.
Was fühlt sich uns, Herr Mario Dietrich?
Ja, wissen Sie, ich habe solchen Husten.
Ich habe das Gefühl, ich kriege ganz schlecht Luft gestern.
Nacht war das ganz unangenehm.
Mit einem Mal habe ich dann so das Gefühl,
dass ich kaum noch Luft bekommen kann.
Das fühlt sich alles ganz eng an.
Das geht gar nicht.
Beim Ausatmen brotelt und brummt das laut.
Ich habe richtig in der Nacht
Erstiegungsangst gehabt.
Jetzt geht es gerade wieder so ein bisschen,
aber ich muss immer noch sehr viel husten.
Man hat mir das schon lange gesagt,
dass ich so ein bisschen empfindliche Bräunchen habe.
Dass die sehr schnell reagieren können.
dass die sehr schnell reagieren, aber dass ich also so Husten habe und so schlecht Luft
bekomme, das habe ich noch nie gehabt und das hat mir auch wirklich ein bisschen Angst gemacht.
Haben Sie, haben Sie Brust angemerkt? Ja, ja, ja, ich hatte auch das Gefühl,
mein Herz klopft ganz tüchtig. Ja, okay. Und seit gestern haben Sie, wie gesagt,
haben Sie hüstelt, ja, gestern. Ja, gestern Abend fing das an und in der Nacht habe ich dann
wirklich nicht gut geschlafen und jetzt bin ich dann gleich heute Morgen hier zu Ihnen gekommen.
Ja, haben Sie die gleiche Beschwerden früher gehabt oder nur seit gestern?
Ja, also Husten habe ich eigentlich schon immer, also dass ich immer so ein bisschen das Gefühl
habe, ich muss so hüsteln, aber jetzt, dass das so, dass das so schlimm ist, dass ich auch das Gefühl
habe, wie gesagt, dass ich gar keine Luft mehr bekommen kann, das habe ich noch vorher noch nicht
gehabt. Ja, haben Sie Brust angemerkt? Ja, so ein enge Gefühl habe ich schon gehabt, ja.
Ja, und haben Sie Kopfschmerzen? Kopfschmerzen habe ich nicht, nein.
Okay, haben Sie Fieber oder haben Sie das Fieber zu Hause gemessen?
Ich habe nicht gemessen, aber fieberig fühle ich mich eigentlich nicht. Ich hatte vor zweieinhalb
Wochen hatte ich eine richtige Erkältung und dann bleibt der Husten immer noch ein bisschen
länger noch, aber ja, jetzt, dass ich also solche Beschwerden habe, habe ich wirklich noch
nicht gehabt. Ja, haben Sie in der letzten Zeit eine lange Reise gemacht?
Nein. Ja, okay. Haben Sie Nachschweiß?
Eigentlich würde ich sagen, nein, habe ich, nein, ist mir nicht aufgefallen. In der
Zeit, als ich da diese Erkältung hatte, da habe ich nachts mal geschwitzt, aber
jetzt in letzter Zeit und regelmäßig nicht. Ja, ist Ihnen übel?
Nein, übel wäre eigentlich mehr so ein Angstgefühl eigentlich.
Angstgefühl, ja, okay. Müssen Sie Sie nicht übergeben?
Übergeben muss ich mich, nein.
Ja, okay. Haben Sie Probleme bei Wasserlassung oder mit Stuhlgang?
Ja, ich habe so ein bisschen neigig zu Verstopfung. Da muss ich dann mal so ein bisschen
vorsichtig essen, dass ich dann etwas, was ich leinsam oder irgendwie so etwas nehme, aber
normal. Okay.
Komm ich da klar.
Ist Ihnen ein bisschen schwindelig?
Nein, schwindelig ist mir auch, glaube ich, heute Nacht nicht gewesen.
Okay. Sie haben gesagt, sehr schwer Luft bekommen und sind die schwer Luft bekommen,
verbunden mit Brustänge oder Brustschmerzen oder nur Haarschmerzen?
Nicht so schmerzhaft, ist es mehr so dieses enge Gefühl?
Wie beschreiben Sie den Hüsten, ist er trocken oder mit Auswurf?
Da ist so ganz zäher Schleim, den kriege ich gar nicht aus.
Ja, haben Sie das, wie sieht der Auswurf aus?
Oh, ich meine, das ist so weissliches Zeug.
Ja, haben Sie etwas Grünes, wenn man?
Nee, nee, nee.
Okay. Ist bei Ihnen allergie bekannt, Herr Dietrich?
Ja, ich darf keine Nüsse essen, da kriege ich ein ganz rotes Gesicht und Kresse kann ich auch nicht vertragen.
Also, Kresse?
Das ist so würziges Kraut, was man so frische Samen, die man keinem lässt.
Das kann man als Salat essen und das ist so würzig und irgendwie kann ich das nicht vertragen.
Ja, okay.
Und jetzt hat man neulich mal festgestellt, dass ich bei Kälte auch so reagiere, dass ich dann auch so einen Juckreiz kriege.
Und die Hände werden dann ganz weiß und kalt und im Gesicht juckt es auch bei Kälte.
Ja, und, äh, Nüsse allergie, äußert sich mit weißer Gesicht oder?
Nee, Rötung, Rötung.
Rötung und dann äußert sich würziges Kraut.
Diese Kresse allergie, ja, das ist bis zur Atemnot gegangen, ja.
Atemnot, ja.
Rauchen Sie, Herr Dietrich?
Nicht mehr, seit drei Jahren rauch ich nicht mehr.
So, drei Jahre, aber vorher rauchen Sie?
Vorher habe ich, ja, zehn Jahre lang habe ich gut geraucht, ja.
Wie viele Zigaretten haben Sie geraucht, am Tag?
Eine Packung am Tag habe ich schon geraucht.
Ja, halbschaftlich.
Eine ganze?
Ja, eine ganze, eine ganze.
Und dann habe ich gemerkt, das bekommt mir gar nicht und ist schlecht mit der Luft und dann habe ich das eingelassen.
Tricken Sie Alkohol?
Nee, gar nicht.
Wo ist das denn?
Ja, mein Vater ist alkoholkrank und das ist so ein abschreckendes Beispiel.
Da lasse ich da von die Finger.
Ja, das ist eine Routinefrage, nehmen Sie bitte das nicht persönlich.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Mit Drogen? Nein, da habe ich nichts mitzutun.
Gott sei Dank.
Nun würde ich über Ihre Vorgeschichte sprechen.
Leiden Sie an chronische Erkrankungen, Herr Dietrich?
Ja, also diese Geschichte mit dem empfindlichen Brunchalsystem, das hat man mir halt gesagt.
Das habe ich aber eigentlich schon seit, als ich ein junger Mann war, habe ich das schon gehabt.
Und dann eben diese Geschichte mit der Reaktion auf Kälte, das ist so relativ neu,
dass die Hände so weiß werden und dass ich so einen Yukrat bekomme bei Kälte.
Ja, okay.
Und sind Sie gegenbrunchenempfindlichkeit?
Nehmen Sie ein irgendwelche Medikamente ein?
Nein, ich nehme nur bei Bedarf Medikamente ein.
Sonst?
Wie läuft es mit Medikamente?
Bitte? Ja, also wenn ich Schmerzen habe, nehme ich halt die Klophenack.
Und wenn das mit der Haut zu unangenehm wird, nehme ich Cortisonsalbe.
Und gegen diese Lungengeschichte, da habe ich bisher noch nichts genommen.
Wenn ich mal Husten habe, dann nehme ich so frei verkäufliche Hustensaft oder so was.
Welche, wie viel Milligramm nehmen Sie?
Die Klophenack ein?
Wie sind Sie?
Weiß ich nicht, ich weiß nur, dass ich da Tabletten zu Hause habe und die nehme ich nach Bedarf ein.
Nun würde ich nach Ihrer Familie vorgeschmackt fragen.
Liebende Eltern noch?
Meine Eltern leben beide noch, aber wie gesagt, mein Vater ist eben ein abschreckendes Beispiel.
Er ist alkoholkrank und er hat zwar eine Entzugsbehandlung hinter sich, aber das hat keinen Effekt gehabt.
Leiden Ihr Vater oder Ihre Mutter eine wichtigen Erkrankung außer dieser Alkoholkrankung?
Meine Mutter hat Nierensteine und die hat in letzter Zeit Probleme mit dem Gucken.
Die hat so einen Gesichtsfeldausfall.
Da ist sie gerade in der Untersuchung, die der Augenarzt guckt, was mit ihr los ist.
Das hat sie mir neulich erzählt, dass sie da ist.
Was hat der Arzt zu Ihrer Mutter gesagt?
Sie sind gerade das zu untersuchen.
Ich weiß noch kein Ergebnis. Sie war erst kürzlich da.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, Geschwister habe ich nicht.
Leiden Ihr Vater außer Alkoholkrankheit andere wichtigen Erkrankungen?
Nicht, dass ich wüsste, da ist nichts bekannt.
Und hat Ihr Vater Leberkrankheit wegen der Alkoholkonsum?
Wahrscheinlich, aber ich weiß nicht genau.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, habe ich schon gesagt.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Nein, ich bin alleine.
Also ich bin ledig.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Kommunikationstrainer, ich mache Gesprächstraining, Beratungstraining und solche Sachen.
Sind Sie auf Stress aufgesetzt?
Nein, ich mache mir das sehr viel Spaß.
Ja, okay.
Und haben Sie nicht Kinder?
Ich habe keine Kinder.
Ja, okay.
Sie haben gesagt, seit gestern haben Sie immer verschlimmende Hüste.
Zwischendurch ist es ein bisschen besser und dann geht es wieder los.
Ja, und ein bisschen haben Sie, Sie haben Brustenge und haben Sie Geschwister und Beine bemerkt?
Das ist mir nicht aufgefallen, nein.
Ja, okay.
Ich habe alle meine wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Und möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Nein, ich glaube, ich habe Ihnen alles erzählt, was es dazu gibt.
Ja, und Entschuldigung, ich habe vergessen, das im Stadion abzufragen.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja, ja, ja.
Gegen Corona weiß ich ganz sicher und alles andere.
Ich bin auch ganz aktuell versorgt.
Ja, okay.
Und sind Sie schon operiert worden?
Ja, ich hatte einmal so eine Gelenkspiegelung im Knie.
Welche Seite?
Auf der linken Seite.
Welche Operation wurden Sie operieren?
Das war eine Artroskopie.
Ja, okay.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Nein, jetzt möchte ich nur, dass das besser wird.
Ja, okay.
Herr Dietrich, ich erkläre Ihnen jetzt, was wir machen wollen.
Ja, und danach möchte ich Sie für eine pfeli Untersuchung machen.
Und danach ein Zugang in den Wehnen.
Und danach möchte ich Ihnen ein bisschen Blut abnehmen.
Weil die brunschige Empfindigkeit ist verbunden mit Entzündungsprozess oder allergischen Reaktionprozess.
Ja, ich möchte wissen, welchen Prozess unter der brunschalen Empfindigkeit.
Ja, und danach alle Ergebnisse, kann ich Ihnen sagen, was Sie haben.
Okay, gut.
Haben Kollegen oder Kolleginnen andere Fragen?
Ich habe eine Frage.
Sind die Beschwerden belustig aufgetreten?
Ja, eigentlich schon, ja.
Sind die Beschwerden erst mal aufgetreten?
Das hat er gefragt, ja.
So in dieser Form ist das erst mal nicht gewesen, ja.
Er hat ein chronisches Brunschalsystem, das hat man ihm bescheinigt.
Also kennt er praktisch Husten, aber dass es so anfaltsartig und mit Luftnot verbunden ist, das kennt er eben nicht.
Sind die Beschwerden tagüber oder in der Nacht aufgetreten?
Die sind am Abend aufgetreten.
Fieber hat er gefragt, habe ich aber verneint, ich habe aber auch nicht gemessen.
Könnte etwas in ihrer Lunge gelangt sein?
Ah, das ist auch interessant, ob ich mich so wie verschluckt oder eingeatmet oder so.
Das ist mir überhaupt nicht aufgefallen, nein.
Haben Sie Halskratzen?
Ja, haben Sie bemerkt, ich habe etwas Luftnoten?
Ich habe nicht bemerkt, kenne ich mich auch nicht mit aus.
Sie haben gesagt, zwei Wochen eine Erkältung gehabt?
Vor zwei Wochen, ja.
Welche Medikamente haben Sie eingenommen?
Da habe ich nur so normalen Hustensaft eingenommen, aber sonst gar nichts.
Malen Nasenspray genommen, aber da bin ich nicht zum Arzt gegangen.
Wie viel Treppen können Sie schmerzfrei laufen?
Gestern Abend hätte ich die Treppe nicht gut hochkommen können, aber normalerweise habe ich keine Probleme.
Müssten Sie Medikisten beim Schlafen?
Nein, nein, nein.
Heute Nacht habe ich immer wieder aufgesessen, aber normalerweise schlafe ich ganz normal.
Haben Sie Herzrahmen oder Herzstoppen bemerkt?
Er hat gesagt, er hat Herzklopfen gehabt.
Wir müssen in sechs Minuten unterbieten, weil der Patient gesagt hat, ein Engel ist in der Brust.
Deswegen müssen wir uns Husten und Pistne, Sauerstoffgabe, Sättigung überprüfen.
Das wäre das, was ich am ersten kritisch zu sagen hätte.
Dieser Patient, ich kann das nicht so gut imitieren, ich kann es nicht so gut imitieren.
Das habe ich nicht durchgehend.
Aber am Anfang habe ich schon ein bisschen markiert, dass ich keine Luftkriege und Husten habe.
Er hat gesagt, er hat ein enges Gefühl, er hat Angst gehabt.
Da wäre sicher angezeigt gewesen, dass man unterbricht und sagt, wir gucken mal, wie ihre Herzaktionen sind.
Wir schauen einmal, wie die Sauerstoffsättigung ist.
Das hätte man ganz sicher machen müssen.
Dann praktisch das Gespräch weiterführen.
Das finde ich auch einen wichtigen Punkt.
Können wir anfangen, Arsatzkirchik?
Ja, Herr Uster, haben Sie das gehört, was wir jetzt zum Schluss gesagt haben?
Ja, ja.
Oder waren Sie so konzentriert, dass Sie gar nicht zugehört haben?
Ja, ich habe gehört und ich musste ein Unterbruch machen.
Weil die Patientin könnte die Patienten schwer Luftkriege und Luftkriege.
Deswegen muss ich die Sauerstoffsättigung überprüfen.
Dann möchte ich weiter machen.
Sie haben gar nicht reagiert, deswegen habe ich gedacht, dass er überhaupt gehört.
Hallo Frau Oberärztin, wir haben heute einen Patienten.
Ich möchte über ihn berichten.
Ja, sehr gut.
Wer haben Sie denn gesehen?
Der Patientin heißt Mario Dietrich.
Er ist 39 Jahre alt und ist nur 300 Jahre alt.
Er ist immer noch ein Mann.
Er wiegt 79 kg.
Und sie ist 1,84 m groß.
Er ist 1 m groß.
Er stammelt sich bei uns wegen seiner gestern bestehenden Hüste.
Er hat früher eine Chronische Branche.
Er hat eine große Allergie mit einem roten Gesicht.
Er hat eine sehr gute Verträglichkeit bei Kälte.
Er ist ihm Blassgesicht aufgefallen.
Er ist seit vielen Jahren ein Branche.
Er nimmt bei Bedarf die Klopfenart und die Unklare Dosierung.
Er nimmt gegen Husten ein Hustenzach.
Er weiß nicht welchen Husten.
Er hat gesagt, er kauft sich etwas freiverkreuzliches.
Er ist am linken Seite durchgeführt.
Er ist durchgeführt.
Er hat eine Erkrankung.
Er ist beruflich Kommunikationstrainer.
Er ist allein.
Er ist in der Erkrankung.
Er kriegt seine Luft nicht raus.